we've got new information on thousands
of migrants most of them from haiti who
camped out near a u.s border crossing in
south texas last month many of them have
made it through some of the most
dangerous wilderness on this planet the
daring gap between panama and colombia
is a jungle filled with wild animals
treacherous terrain and armed criminals
cbs news has reported extensively from
this area manuel bajorkas is in nicoley
colombia talking to migrants who are
still just trying to get through manuel
good morning to you
good morning to you gail it is estimated
some 16 000 migrants are waiting here in
colombia for a chance to cross this bay
to get themselves one step closer to a
stretch of jungle known as the darian
gap many of them wait weeks camped out
along this beach here and word that the
u.s has recently deported nearly 7 000
haitians is doing very little to stop
them
a patchwork of tents has replaced the
sun bathing tourists that once dotted
the beaches of nekkoclei
its spot along the caribbean coast has
made it the next stop for migrants
heading north like charles patrick where
do you want us usa usa the united states
that's his goal he fled poverty and
violence in haiti four years ago he says
only to find discrimination and little
work in chile he has two daughters back
home a young woman and a girl
so everything you do is for them
i want to change their life my
my family you want to change their lives
too
the shortest route from here to panama
is by boat but that nation's government
is only allowing 500 to cross a day
creating a bottleneck
there are clues here pointing to the
hard journey ahead they want these types
of shoes because
they know it's so dangerous out there
but
they're expensive so he's only sold two
pairs so far
the danger is the darian gap a 60-mile
stretch of lawless jungle so treacherous
at least 50 bodies have reportedly been
found this year but the real death toll
is estimated to be four times higher
more than 88 thousand have already
crossed this year panama estimates one
out of every four are children
their road map is a network of whatsapp
groups with migrants sharing directions
tips
first you must leave nekoclii leonel
nelson his wife and his infant daughter
are about to do just that and attempt to
cross the gap
that it's very difficult that there are
bandits but despite the danger nelson is
determined to push ahead we were with
them as they waited and finally got a
chance to board
we followed leonel and his family as
they crossed and handed themselves over
to smugglers on the other side to
continue their journey
we'll have that part of the story for
you tomorrow right here on cbs mornings
tony
boy manny showing us the dangers of that
journey and in doing so suggesting what
dangers laid behind what would you leave
behind
to do that that's your choice manny
thank you very much look forward to that
piece tomorrow